hi there today we're looking at this
news story from MIT technology review
Google's medical AI was super-accurate
in a lab real life was a different story
so the story here is that Google had
this AI to detect diabetic retinopathy
so if you're a diabetic and you your
glucose isn't or your insulin isn't
properly handled that means you get
damage to your blood vessels and the
small blood vessels like the ones in the
eyes here they're the first ones to get
damaged and that can lead you to get
this disease called retinopathy which
are is in the retina in the back of the
eye and that can lead you to go blind if
it's not discovered soon enough
so a eye doctor can look at an
photograph like this and can determine
whether you have it or not
I guess they would look at like a larger
resolution of it but in any case they
could determine from this so Google
built an AI that could maybe spot things
here that may be spot if you had this or
not and they tried to deploy this and
the story is about how this failed
basically so they said they had the this
in Thailand they had the opportunity to
deploy this so Thailand's Ministry of
Health had set an annual goal to screen
60% of the people with diabetes for this
diabetic retinopathy it can cause
blindness if not caught early so here is
where I comes in because to four point
five million patients that have diabetes
there are only 200 experts that can
determine from a photograph whether or
not you do have that disease so they say
clinics are struggling to meet the
target and Google has built a AI says
the am i developed by Google have can
identify signs of diabetic retinopathy
from an eye scan with more than 90%
accuracy which the team calls human
specialist level and gives results in
less than 10 minutes all right so this
is pretty cool right they've developed
an AI you can send an eye scan and it'll
say what what you whether or not you
have this disease but then the problems
mount they so they followed over several
months they observe nurses conducting
eye scans and interviewed them about
their expertise using the new system so
the nurses who conduct the eye scans
they would try to use the AI and they
they the nurses themselves aren't
specialists they would otherwise send
the scans to a specialist but now they
are supposed to handle this up when it
worked well the AI did speed things up
so but sometimes failed to give a result
at all
so these AI had been trained on high
quality scans right if of course if you
want to train an AI system you want the
highest quality data you can get but
also in practice you're not gonna get
high quality data it was designed to
reject images that fell below a certain
threshold of quality and they say often
often taking the photos and poor
lighting conditions in the real world
more than a fifth of the images were
rejected so this is my take on it if you
build something for the real world you
need to take into account what the real
world holds in store for you which means
that you probably are going to have poor
lighting conditions if you build an
image recognition system right now I'm
not saying that like some people are
saying whenever you work with AI you
should consider how it impacts later on
and so on no it's perfectly fine to work
on a data set of high quality images if
you do something like invent a new
architecture or whatnot work on
optimization algorithms well like not
nothing of that but it is if you are
thinking of deploying something in the
real world you need to take this into
account
now I also think this was particularly
poorly designed for the task and here is
why Google
here is mainly worried about legal
culpability because the thing says it
was designed to reject images that fell
below a certain threshold of quality
right the reason for this is that here
you have a classifier right and either
it says it says okay here is positive
and negative class I am about this much
sure of the positives clause in this
much of the negative class and there's
quite a big of a difference here right
so I'm gonna go with the negative class
but if those two things are somewhat
closer together the Google doesn't trust
its own AI it's like yeah and if it did
some decision here if it's as well I
still go go with the negative class
right this goes back to the patient and
they made a mistake then this thing here
is automatically responsible for that
mistake and since the AI is not a human
these mistakes here could be rather
trivial mistakes that a human would have
spotted so basically since it's deep
learning we don't really trust it and
then because Google doesn't want the
legal culpability of being responsible
they simply reject these cases they just
say we don't deal with it we just deal
with things with a large discrepancy if
you actually want to design something
for the real world you need to take into
account ok there's poor lighting
conditions and I would think in if I
were to build something like this
optimally you would just output this
thing you would output this distribution
you would in this case you could say
look I am 60 40 % I'm not sure I lean
towards negative but I don't think so
and then the nurse who ought maybe also
has some expertise could be experienced
in when the system fails or when it
tends to be not sure and could kind of
integrate that information but this only
works so if you are a that's maybe a
recommendations for lawgivers this only
works if you don't make the AI system
completely culpable for
it's mistakes it can output its
estimation and it can along of that it
can actually also output an estimation
of its own uncertainty you can like give
you some confidence bounds here that
these are not going to be statistical
true confidence bounds because it's deep
learning but still I would say please
give all the available information that
the system has and then let the humans
work with the system rather than trying
to fully replace the humans by simply
saying yes/no or reject all right so
they say patients whose images were
kicked out of the system were told they
could have a visit they would have to
visit a specialist at another clinic on
another day if they found it hard to
take time off work or did not have a car
this was obviously inconvenient which I
can understand nurses felt frustrated
especially when they believe the
rejected scans showed no sign of disease
and the follow-up appointments were
unnecessary this is exactly what I'm
saying right
the nurses often also have very good
experience and can combined could
combine something like this with their
own experience of when something is
wrong and when something isn't wrong and
maybe you even building some explain
ability to focus on part of the image
and then you could alleviate a lot of
these problems
they sometimes waste the time time to
retake or edit an image that the AI had
rejected right this this is just now
you're just build AI working against
humans rather than with humans so
further it says because the system had
to upload images to the cloud for
processing poor internet connection in
several clinics also caused delays so
patients like the instant results but
the internet is slow and the patient's
then complain they've been waiting here
since 6:00 a.m. and for the first two
hours could only we could only screen 10
patients yes this is the type of stuff
you have to take into account so maybe
actually put the GPU server into the
clinic it's
better anyway for for data privacy
reasons but of course the large
companies they want to everything to be
uploaded to their machines it's more
convenient for them so they say there is
now working with medical staff to design
a new workflows I mean sometimes you do
rely on an internet connection so I
don't want to be too too harsh here so
the the other there are some critics
here so Michael
Abramov an eye doctor and computer
scientist at the University of Iowa
Hospitals and Clinics has been
developing an AI for diagnosing retinal
disease for several years and is a CEO
of a spin-off here and he basically says
there is much more to health care than
algorithms and I mean of course we can
we can all we can all see that yeah it
basically says that the questions the
usefulness of comparing AI tools with
human specialists when it comes to
accuracy of course we don't want Nia to
make a bad call but human doctors
disagree all the time he says that's
fine my assistant needs to fit into a
process where sources of uncertainty are
discussed rather than simply rejected
and this exact this exactly feeds into
what I've been saying if the error just
to output the source of uncertainty and
all it thinks about a particular
situation then the humans could discuss
it right and then we could get to a
better outcome but this only works if
the legal framework is given if you
regulate and I get I get that point too
you want to assign kind of blame when
something goes wrong but you just have
to know that this is what keeps these
systems back often finally they say the
benefits could be huge there was one
nurse that screened 1,000 patients on
her own
what time that is I guess that's over
the course of the study or so and with
this tool she's unstoppable the patients
didn't really care that it was an AI
rather than a human reading their images
they cared more about what their
experience was going to be and that's a
general extent general experience that I
get from a lot of people working with
human machine interactions is that the
people don't they're not so super
excited that it's a human if they if the
machine appears competent I think we've
gotten used to AI being quite good at
particular tasks and we're actually
happy to outsource some of these to them
but again if you build something for the
real world
you have to take into account the
real-world conditions and this feeds
into papers like image net v2 where you
all of a sudden have a harder test set
it feeds into topics like domain shift
transfer learning domain adaptation and
these are all research topics so I think
problems like this can give rise to
entirely new directions of research if
you're looking for the PhD topic maybe
this is something for you all right
thanks for watching this this was my
blabs about the story I hope you enjoyed
this in these kind of new sections it's
a new thing I'm doing if you liked it
subscribe if you didn't like it leave a
comment and bye bye